I just found out like two minutes ago that Lorraine Warren, the author of the cases
that some of these Conjuring movies are based on,
has just passed away.
So I'm gonna go ahead and dedicate this episode of Things You Missed to Lorraine Warren.
If you want to hear about how La Llorona sets
up for another movie, then stick around to
the end of this video.
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
But first, rant time.
I know it's become kind of a horror cliche
for a character to brush off something supernatural
by telling themself it was just in their imagination,
but The Curse of La Llorona takes this to
the most ridiculous level I've ever seen.
Like almost every character has ample opportunity
to say, "Hey, that thing that just happened.
That wasn't normal.
Maybe I should get help.
Maybe I should make like Andre 3000 and get
up and go to church."
But they don't.
It's so frustrating.
Like those two Alvarez boys who tell the social
worker that, "she'll hurt us" if they leave
the closet.
Why would you say that and not clarify that
you're talking about a spooky ghost and not
their mother who's being investigated?
And then the main family is even worse.
They each have individual encounters with
La Llorona, and when asked what happened,
they're like, "no, nothing happened."
The Mom, I get, she has to uphold her credibility
because she has a job.
But the kids have no reason to hide it, and
it’s just completely illogical.
And then, around the midpoint, they all encounter
La Llorona together, and then they basically
get together and decide, "Nope, that was nothing
right?
We didn't see anything."
But anyway, that was frustrating, let's move
onto the Things You Missed.
The first clue that this is just the Conjuring
but with Spanish legends, comes as soon as
we get into the main setting of the movie,
Los Angeles 1973.
A long, fast-moving handheld tracking shot
takes us through the house in the exact same
style of the opening of The Conjuring.
When we first meet Anna's daughter Sam, she's
watching an episode of Scooby Doo.
This is probably the point where everyone
leaves a comment about me being Shaggy's brother,
so I'm only gonna use 0.1% of my power to
extract this Thing You Missed.
The episode she is watching features someone
pretending to be a ghost in order to terrorize
people, as many Scooby Doo episodes do.
At the end of The Curse of La Llorona, we
are led to believe, however obvious it may
have been, that La Llorona broke the fire
seed barrier setup at the door and got into
the house, when in reality, it was actually
Patricia Alvarez, the mother who had her two
sons taken by La Llorona, and thought by sacrificing
Anna's kids, she could get hers back.
She wears similar clothing and takes off her
shoes to give her the appearance of the ghost,
just like the villain in that Scooby Doo episode.
The actress who plays Anna also played Velma
in the live action Scooby Doo movies.
The scene where Samantha sees La Llorona through
the clear umbrella next to the swimming pool
is very reminiscent of a short film called
Cam Closer, in which the supernatural occurrences
only show up through a cell phone camera.
I’d like to believe that the umbrella scene
isn’t blatant plagiarism, because the director
of Cam Closer, David F Sandberg, also directed
Annabelle Creation, which is a part of this
universe, so maybe they had his blessing to
lift the concept.
I’d still love to see Cam Closer adapted
into a feature film in the style of Lights
Out.
But speaking of the lights being out, and
yes, I’m aware that was a terrible transition,
during the scene that takes place in the middle
of the night where Anna calls out asking if
someone is in the house… as if the intruder
or ghost is just going to be like “oh you
got me, April Fools!”
But as Anna goes back into her room, if you
look to the right side of the doorway, you
can spot La Llorona just standing there in
the corner, hiding in the dark.
Now I was going to point out that Father Perez
is the same priest that helps out Mia and
John in Annabelle, but the movie makes it
pretty clear when he explains that he opened
his mind to things out of the ordinary after
an incident with a doll, so I'll point out
a couple of other Annabelle connections instead.
Misty is the name of the doll that Sam carries
around, and nearly kills them all when she
accidentally breaks the fire seed barrier
when trying to grab the doll from outside.
It resembles a Raggedy Ann doll, the real
life version upon which the Annabelle doll
is based on.
Also, in my last episode when I talked about
the Annabelle Comes Home trailer, one of the
things I pointed out was this wedding dress
in the Warren’s room of cursed objects.
Now that La Llorona is confirmed to be part
of The Conjuring universe, I think it's very
likely that this is La Llorona's dress.
Anna is, afterall, able to collect the sapphire
locket off while trying to banish her from
the house, so it stands to reason that by
fully defeating the weeping woman, Ed and
Lorraine Warren could at some point obtain
this dress.
It is hinted that she survives at the end
of the movie, based on the final shot where
Anna looks back and sees something in the
reflection of the puddle, which is consistent
with numerous occasions of La Llorona appearing
in mirrors and causing them to break.
But does this mean we are going to see La
Llorona Dos?
Well I have a better suggestion.
The Conjuring and The Conjuring 2 both open
with Ed and Lorraine Warren on a case that’s
unrelated to the main case of the movie.
The director of The Curse of La Llorona was
Michael Chaves who is also supposed to direct
The Conjuring 3.
Father Perez tells Anna that the church has
people who can deal with evil spirits, but
it takes several weeks for these things to
be approved by the church.
We see the same thing happen in The Conjuring,
where the exorcism isn’t approved until
after it’s already over.
"The vatican approved the exorcism."
"Hm. Nice timing."
So my idea is that Father Perez puts in the
request for Anna anyways, and the opening
of The Conjuring 3, or really any Conjuring
movie, shows La Llorona being defeated, her
spirit being locked inside of the wedding
dress which is kept safely in Ed Warren’s
home.
As far as further connections go, the Shaman
Rafael who helps out the family explains he
no longer works with the church and he made
it seem like there’s some history there
-- so I wouldn’t be too surprised to see
more of his story in another movie.
This next one is a bit of a spoiler if you
haven’t seen The Conjuring 2, but I think
we all kind of know what happens.
When they finally do banish La Llorona by
stabbing her with the cross, she disappears
in a manner that looks almost exactly like
the defeat of Valak at the end of The Conjuring
2 where Lorraine banishes the demon back to
hell, so it seems possible that neither one
of these entities is gone for good.
I’m gonna be doing a little mini marathon
where I’ll be covering all thee Annabelle
movies here on Things You Missed, so remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring the deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.